last game we need a little pep talk here
what do we got this is the old note
pardon we don't got much we don't there
we go you won the last game no this is
the what game we're gonna remember Bob
you're our senior state right make a
statement yeah hi there yeah that was
the dressing room before the game
it's our last game of the year we won by
quite a margin we gathered at the pub
for lunch I videoed everyone on my
iPhone ask them all what would motivate
them to learn a language but I'm so bad
at these things I didn't have I had run
out of space on my iPhone so we won't
get to see that one fellow said that he
wanted to learn polish because his wife
was polish and after 33 years of
marriage he wanted to understand what
his wife's family was saying about them
there's a motivation so I can't help it
I shouldn't but I'm going to talk about
language and politics with specific
reference to the situation in Ukraine
one of the joys of having learned
Russian is that I can watch programs
like an exchange between telecom outdoor
switches that is an independent
television station in Russia and
katakana it cannot channel in Ukraine
there were about eight people on the
Ukrainian side maybe eight or nine
people on the Russian side and they kind
of went back and forth the first thing
that impressed me is that all of these
Ukrainian television personalities that
I had been listening to in Ukrainian and
not understanding of course they spoke
Russian absolutely I mean to my mind
flawless Russian I couldn't tell the
difference between them and the Russian
it always impresses me when people are
so fluent in two languages completely at
home in two languages the the Russian
the Ukrainian side is more or less
united in their condemnation of the
actions of the Russian government the
Russian president and of course their
defense of the territorial integrity of
Ukraine including the Crimea the Russian
side is more divided
I think telecom outdoors had made a
point of inviting a variety of different
people some who are very you know
pro-government some who are who question
what the government is doing is over so
you had a bit of a divergence of opinion
what came out of the Russian side it's
prickly those that supported the Putin
and the Russian government was that they
felt the important issues were that do
you create the people in the Crimea
wanted independence and have the right
to self-determination and that Russia
has the right to protect Russians ethnic
Russians who live in other countries and
to protect or work or foster the proper
role for the Russian language there was
a fair amount of misinformation I don't
know whether what all is true or not
I hear from a lot of Ukrainians even
russian-speaking Ukrainians that they
are not in any way discriminated against
in Ukraine however I heard an interview
between Alexey venediktov of echo Mosby
and the Minister of Education in the new
government and he said that in the
universities in Ukraine there are two
languages Ukrainian and English I say to
myself when so much of the population
speak such excellent Russian why
wouldn't Russian be a language of
instruction in the universities you can
still have everyone learning cranium in
elementary school but if you're a
scientist if you're publishing papers if
you want to go and study I mean you've
got beside you a country that's three
times your size with an international
repetition as does the Ukraine as
Ukraine but but why would you why do you
have to have English and Ukrainian at
the expense of Russia I don't understand
I think that's not wise however I'm not
Ukrainian I have no right to say what
they do I can offer my opinion on it but
then the Russian government does also
not have the right to impose anything on
Ukraine there might be international
meetings about the role of
you know other international languages
such as Russian which is an
international language there are many
ways of putting pressure on them and
raising this issue but it's not
justification for any kind of military
action similarly I think the Crimean
issue is by no means the central issue
in here if the issue simply were the
self-determination of the people in the
Crimean they could have dealt with that
ten years ago they could have had an
international conference on it they
could have could have done a number of
things the Russian side said for example
we have the right to station 25,000
troops this is not an invasion but
that's not true there's so much of what
the Russian side says which they hear on
their you know media there which is
simply not true they have the right to
station troops there on their naval base
they don't have the right to overrun the
Crimean with soldiers dressed in you
know Russian army gear didn't you know
driving around in Russian military
vehicles with Russian weapons without
their signature on taking over strategic
Ukrainian assets that's just not true
that's an invasion from the base it's
still an invasion also the the idea that
that the I mean if the people in the in
the in the Crimea wanna have
independence I don't know maybe they
should be able to have a referendum on
it but not in 10 days not in the present
state of hysteria Scotland's gonna have
a refugee you know and again the
Russians say well or Scotland has a
referendum in Independence yeah it's
taking two years to organize we've had
referendums in Quebec for two years
twice and it takes time to organize
there's all kinds of rules and stuff but
I still you know because we have the
situation Quebec I I can see where the
Ukrainians are coming from because they
are trying to create their you know
strengthen that sense of nation-state
around their language and so they feel
that their that Russian is so much more
powerful as a language as an
international language that they have to
create space for Ukraine just as in
Quebec the québécois like in Quebec when
I lived there at least eighteen percent
of the popular
was English speaking and yet English is
not an official language in Quebec now a
lot of half the english-speaking
population has left so now the
english-speaking population is only 10%
but that's still a lot of people it's
800,000 or so people yet it's not an
official language in Quebec to my mind
what would it hurt them to have English
as official language there Montreal was
a totally bilingual City and yet the the
nationalists the Quebec nationally they
seek to try to deny in fact that
Montreal is bilingual I think
bilingualism is bad almost some of the
Nationalists and yet on the other hand
if I look at the reaction of English
Canadians towards the legitimate sort of
national aspirations of the québécois
french-speaking North Americans they're
very unsympathetic like zero I wouldn't
say all of them but a lot of them and
there is sort of like well we won the
war and whenever it was the Battle of
Quebec so just shut up and you're lucky
we let you speak French that type of
attitude is quite common and so it's a
big brother small brother thing which
creates a lot of resentment on the side
of the québécois who sense that
similarly Canadians base of the
Americans we often have the sense that
they're big they do what they want they
come in with heavy feet and what's good
for them is good for us and as a
consequence there is actually a fair
amount of sort of anti-americanism in
Canada most of it not justified and not
justified at all in my opinion but it's
there
and I I kind of see some of those big
brothers small brother relationships
between the Russians and the Ukrainians
the Ukrainian being small brother so
they have the small brother complex and
the Russians kind of thing well you know
you guys hey you're just inventing your
identity anyway and you should just do
what we tell you and then we get to run
things in your country but you don't get
to run things in our country kind of
thing so all of those things are playing
you know in the in the state but the big
thing to my mind is you know as as I
mean we're in a small world today like I
can sit here in my little room here in
Vancouver and I can watch this
discussion between people and
and between Moscow and Kiev that's
amazing and because I speak the language
okay so you gotta be able to speak the
language and so I mean I remember
reading when I read the 1830s 1812 I
mean warranties and Tolstoy talks about
how what led up to this tremendous you
know tragic I mean hundreds of thousands
of people losing their lives as a result
of Napoleon's invasion of Russia and it
starts with one decision here another
decision there another decision there
and pretty soon this kind of gathers
momentum and it has a sort of a life of
its own it's like the First World War
people went off to war all you know
beating their chests and you know the
Germans even the Socialists in Germany
in France that everywhere they all voted
to go to war and and you know four years
later however many millions of people
have died for nothing so there are no
quick and easy Wars it's gonna be pretty
messy now the Russians are massing
troops I gather if I believe what I hear
in the eastern part of the Ukraine I
mean I understand it this is Putin he
doesn't move softly like he doesn't move
softly internally or externally he
didn't like the fact that he he felt
that events are not new in Ukraine were
out of his control so he was gonna
re-establish control so he's gonna take
the Crimea with his troops stationed
there in there they're black sea fleet
base there and he's gonna rattle his
saber and he's make the Ukrainians
realize you know we're much more
powerful in you and we're very United
because he's clamping down increasingly
on on the press in Russia although here
we have this telecom outdoors so it's
not that black and white but he wants to
make them realize that you know you're
not gonna and and to the extent that
there is a danger that the people in
power and care have too much influence
from these extreme nationalist groups
the Putin is providing a counterweight
to that and initially I think in an
attempt to influence events and
hopefully this would lead them to an
election where we would have a
government in the Ukraine that would be
balanced
appeal to a broad spectrum of the
Ukrainian society maintain good
relations with Russia
and not be in a hurry to charge off and
join Europe so this was his means of
trying to control the situation
hopefully things don't get out of hand
that's I would like to wake up on Monday
and see that there's an international
conference on Crimea Ukraine all this
kind of stuff and how everything's gonna
be calmed down again interesting - on
sanctions the British probably not too
keen on having too many sanctions on
Russian assets abroad because the London
City benefits tremendously from this
Russian investments in in London of
course the Germans rely on Russian gas
so the whole thing is pretty complicated
hopefully we can start edging towards a
de-escalation sometime soon and I think
in that sense even though there was not
that much agreement between the Russians
and the Ukrainians in this exchange I
mean that's the kind of thing you have
to have you have to have people talking
in that sense - I listen to an interview
with the head of the Crimean Tatars who
had been visited with Vladimir Putin
which is again extremely important
because he is very much a pro you know
my government the Ukrainian government
so I'm sure he went there as well with
some instructions from the Ukrainian
government and there were he didn't tell
us everything that he had to say to
Vladimir Putin so hopefully things calm
down and I hope that doesn't get too
many people on either side of this
dispute angry at me although probably it
will factor